Barry I date an ftth Council Europe
produced the latest figures for FTTH
today what for you were some of the
major trends that came out of that we
saw that during the nine first months of
2015 the growth was still there even if
there were no specific or significant
events in one country or another so now
what can say is that Europe has entered
the fiber age and that the growth is
becoming structural the gross is they're
both in terms of subscribers and homes
past that's brilliant news and now we've
now we're in the fiber age as you as you
put it what do you think we will see
next what is the next objective for
Europe for Europe maybe the next
objective will be to provide higher and
higher speed rates to end user the
objective of the Digital Agenda are 30
megabits coverage for all citizens and
half households connected with 100
megabits per second connection maybe the
objective the next step will be to be
able to provide higher speed rate speed
rates to end-users and provide a list
gigabit cranston do you think that we
will hit the target of the Digital
Agenda there seems to be a lot of doubt
whether Europe will make it what do you
think I think that in terms of coverage
and thanks to the technological mix that
could be provided could be implemented
this objective will be probably reached
the in terms of subscriptions have
households connected at 100 megabit per
second may not be reached on time it
will be reached for sure maybe not at up
to 20 20 maybe a little bit later and
maybe we will have good surprise and it
can be also reached earlier fantasy well
let's hope so now we talked about the
about FTTH now providing a platform for
Europe there's lots more technologies
coming online we're all talking about
the Internet of Things we're talking
about 5g do you think this platform is
going to help Europe integrate things
like Internet of Things I'm pretty
convinced that indeed IOT or 5g are
among the drivers for FTTH and users
will have will want for sure good fixed
and good wireless connections and will
want to be able to use all the devices
they have at home so there those are
drivers for FTTH foster but we thank you
so much for the report thank you for the
inside it's given us to us and thank you
for speaking to us today thank you very
much